alors oui je crois que effectivement
comme l'a rappelé votre invité en
plateau le mérite de l'église catholique
et de ne pas avoir eu peur quelles que
soient les coûts qu'elle allait recevoir
par la suite de ne pas avoir eu peur de
la vérité et contrairement à d'autres
institutions et qui peuvent parfois
laisser les fesses enterré de même elle
est allée chercher alors il a fallu pour
cela beaucoup de temps probablement que
cette décision de sa part en france en
tout cas est arrivé trop tard beaucoup
trop tard mais elle est allée chercher
elle-même la vérité et en confiant à se
sauver c'est que le choix de prese de
cette commission elle est à les traquer
presque une à une les les abuseurs en
son propre sein pour essayer d'offrir un
recensement exhaustif des victimes et en
tant que catholique évidemment là la
vérité ainsi mises à nu est extrêmement
douloureuse elle vient ébranler notre
rapport à toute l'institution à sa
hiérarchie mais finalement à travers
elle à chaque prêtre aujourd'hui un
catholique qui a pris connaissance de ce
rapport se demande presque
systématiquement si tel ou tel prêtre
ami de la famille où parents peut être
de ceux là aussi et en même temps ce
travail fait pour la vérité je crois que
l'église catholique aujourd'hui est la
seule institution à l'avoir accompli
jusqu au bout et en cela et bien
peut-être que dans sa déchéance
peut-être que dans son déshonneur elle
retrouve justement une forme de dignité
au moment même où on croyait
l'institution à terre alors pourquoi
l'église catholique il ya effectivement
des questions dont on pourra débattre
tout au long de la soirée dans le dogme
chrétien dans la façon dont elle prépare
aussi ses prêtres sacerdoce mais je
crois surtout que aujourd'hui la vérité
dans l'église catholique s'est rendu
coupable s'est rendu coupable elle a
établi elle même et peut-être que on
aura la désagréable surprise de se
rendre compte que malheureusement peu
d'institutions
sont épargnés par cette vague d'abus
sexuels de violences sexuelles sur en
particulier les mineurs qui je crois est
un phénomène dont on sous-estimé
l'importance partout dans la société et
d'ailleurs les chiffres que la
commission sauvé a permis d'établir à la
suite d'une enquête sociologique très
précises sont effarants on se rend
compte que c'est une présent extrêmement
fortement dont beaucoup de familles en
france donc énormément d'endroits c'est
quelque chose je crois que c'est
ablement l'un des maux du 21ème siècle
face auxquels on va devoir
regarder la réalité en face les enfants
abusés sont malheureusement extrêmement
nombreux et on nous a certainement
sous-estimé jusqu'à maintenant et la
parole se libérant on va probablement
aller de découverte en découverte à
chaque fois avec effroi
[Musique]